I'm very happy to bring you our next
guest he was the vice president United
States and I think it was we all know he
should have been the president of United
States unfortunately he's not the
president states now but I wish he was
Al Gore how are you hey Bill gosh that
thunderous applause is just so
gratifying thank you I do use a laugh
drackett parts of the show I love you
know but are you okay I know you're a
very social creature yeah back with you
are you okay sequestering yeah I'm okay
thank you for asking and I hope you are
too you look great well I'm doing my own
makeup I feel like Laurence Olivier at
the old yeah there in the mirror but so
the Pope who I don't usually quote said
today that this is nature's response the
virus to climate change he quoted
something from he said in Spanish we say
God always forgives but nature never
forgives you see it that this way that
this is sort of nature's way of saying
you know you can go on killing the earth
for just so long before you kill
yourself well we've been encroaching
into these wild areas and reducing the
overall extent of them so that the
number of times when human beings come
into contact with wild creatures that
Harbor viruses like the corona virus
those occasions are increasing so there
is there is that connection but the the
real connection in my opinion is that
you know the scientists have warned us
about the corona virus and they've
warned us about the climate crisis and
we've seen the dangers of waiting too
late to heed the warnings of the doctors
and scientists on this virus and we
should not wait any longer to heed their
warnings about what we're doing to
radically destabilize the Earth's
climate and perhaps that connection is
obvious but some things you think are
obvious take some time to become obvious
to
governmental officials sometimes yeah
yeah you know people brag at this moment
I notice about how adaptable humans are
I don't find that comforting because I
don't want us to adapt to everything you
know we were never the masked people and
now we're just gonna be the people who
adapt that way the the air in Los
Angeles has has not been this good since
it belonged to Mexico but people will do
it for the virus they won't do it for
carbon yeah it's interesting and by the
way there's a brand new study out this
week that shows that burning fossil
fuels and polluting the air with the
exhaust emissions is in effect a
pre-existing condition that raises the
death rate from kovat 19 and so it's odd
well it's understandable we know the
reasons why but it's odd and strange and
wrong that the president would pick this
time to suspend enforcement of the
environmental laws and tell the
polluters they can just crank up all the
pollution they want into the air because
it kills more people we know that now
and it's also by the way you've talked
very eloquently about the racial
disparities for those who are suffering
from koban 19 you know african-americans
and to an extent Hispanic Americans
Native Americans are way more likely to
live downwind from the smokestacks and
adjacent to the hazardous waste storage
sites and flows and that's why for
example Bill for a long time the death
rate from asthma for African American
children in the u.s. is 10 times greater
than the death rate from asthma for
white children and so we see these
disparities with koban 19 and there are
other reasons for it access to medical
care economic inequality the kind of
jobs available and other things too but
the exposure to much more air pollution
is one of the main factors it is a pre
fossil
fuels are a pre-existing condition for
kovat 19 right so the political calculus
changed this week Bernie Sanders dropped
out as you know the men who had your old
job Joe Biden is now obviously going to
be the candidate what would you think
about Biden naming Obama Coronas virus
czar right now he did really good with
the Ebola virus you think that would
excite people to get to the polls
knowing that Obama was going to be in
charge of handling this disease as
opposed to the way it's being handled at
the top right now well he might want to
check with President Obama first he
might not want he might not want to take
that position but of course Barack Obama
would be extremely capable at any thing
that he was assigned to question whether
or not Biden would want to do that right
now but it's not a bad idea bill so I
know if you I'm sure you saw this week
what happened in Wisconsin it looked to
me like a dry run for what the
Republicans are going to try to do in
the fall which is as what they always do
with elections cheap people were
standing in line it was their primary
the Democrats wanted the election to be
postponed
the republican-led state court would not
allow that to happen so for example
Milwaukee where there was supposed to be
a hundred and eighty two polling places
open there was only five open I mean if
that happened in the fall the Democrat
could never win in Wisconsin one of the
key swing states of course that was very
close last time it also looks like
president Trump is touting the line that
mail-in votes are somehow now fraudulent
which is pretty funny when you think
about someone going to a polling place
with a mask on it would seem like an
easier way to commit fraud than doing it
by mail but as someone who was cheated
out of an election what do you think
about all that well
you know I think it's tragic that the
modern Republican Party has become so
committed to suppressing voter turnout
and that's relatively well I start
saying it's relatively new I come from
the south where it's been going on a
long time but I think back to when
Republicans like Jim Sensenbrenner and
others helped to lead the way to a
renewal of the Voting Rights Act not
that long ago but now they're committed
to suppressing the vote and you know
their theory is that the wealthy and
powerful and politically connected just
know better and they ought to be in
charge that's fundamentally wrong you've
heard the phrase the wisdom of crowds
the real secret to America's success for
two centuries is that we've made better
decisions until recent until the last
couple of decades by trusting in the
judgment of the American people but you
know what happened in Wisconsin you're
right is a warning
I'd like to float an idea on your show
bill we need mass testing to see who has
the antibodies and who's free and clear
of the disease at least for a time we
need to know more about who's infected
and who's not because there are so many
asymptomatic carriers what if some
governor started the ball rolling by
setting up testing sites at every
polling place for the November election
we've got to 5 5 to 6 months to mass a
workforce and get the quick return test
to do that we ought to start the testing
even sooner than that we that's been one
of the many great failures and our
country's response to this thus far but
we've got to get on with the testing and
we can supplement whatever we get done
quickly by setting it up at polling
places and if it became popular red
state governors might want to join in
also it's a great idea
you're still an idea guy Al and I
appreciate that I appreciate you I thank
you for doing this in this difficult
time and I hope to see you on the real
set pretty soon I hope so too bill and
thanks for your long-term faithful fight
against the climate crisis lots of
people and me we really appreciate it
thank you thanks
I appreciate it see you soon
you